a votre avis il tient à votre avis qui a
exposé la exploser la voiture de sa mère
alors qu'il faisait le mur ici autour de
la table non non non c'est pas voiture
louvière non non non c'est pas boudé
vous c'est pas moi jean michel c'est
jean-michel brabois gâteau dictionnaire
s'est passé exactement
j'habitais à l'époque à epinal donc
grecque un mec qui fait le mur s'est
élancé j'avais pas l'euro de peur de
sortir je suis plus que j'avais des
examens en croûte j'étais grand rejeté
pathogènes et moi j'avais une voiture
quand même j'avais une jeep à l'époque
quoi à mennevret jeep débarquement pas
une banshee pas dieu j'avais 18 ans 19
ans et voilà et du coup je recule je
récupère sortirait pas 18 ans faites
vous votre vie elle a fait comme ça
save ulysse et lancia débutante mais là
il va arriver à la station gare et donc
plus il est n'est plus zz va vers les 3
4 ans avant j'avais trois ans j'avais un
dragster
j'ai reculé pour sorti chez moi il
fallait se passionna et je fasse un
demi-tour dans le chemin sur habiter à
la campagne et j'ai reculé j'ai fait
demi tour et j'ai entendu un énorme choc
j'avais complètement zappé que ma mère
avec sa voiture qui était garée dans le
coin dans l'angle mort des voitures gex
du coup j'ai avancé j'ai été me
recoucher jusqu'au matin dix ans
peut-être que personne n'aurait rien vu
ne peuvent pas ma mère était faire les
courses elle a vu sa voiture défoncée et
la chercher mais comme j'étais le seul
dans la maison selon l'âge et
l'interrogatoire était vite mené
d'avouer à bah oui bah le vmm les traces
de la peinture m'a battu à l'aventuré
mais la presse doit le maire sur la
voiture donc ils préfèrent constat
famille en a parmi vous qui a envoyé un
texto à sa femme alors qu'il voulait
l'envoyer reproducteurs fondre avec
apache
alors joe maddon qu'il envoyait un
sex-toy sa femme au lieu d'envoyer à sa
maîtresse il va nous raconter sa tante
en instance devait être une baby sitter
de départ c'est une belle histoire n est
pas un droit j'aurais pu avoir le texto
qu'il envoyait fait je sais qui était sa
femme à l'époque non sachez que c'est
quelqu'un que vous aimez femme est
partie et j'ai envoyé un texto c'est bon
le champ est libre
bien vite et bien vite envoyé je me
rends compte que c'est parti en fait à
ma femme aulas est là quant à la petite
barque s'affiche comme ça c'est fait et
bah non il est arrivé quand même je me
rappelle pascal tournée star à demain et
après quand ça vous rappelle vous faites
non mesdames évidemment je suis
impatient que tout retrouver dans
lesquelles vous donniez votre femme
manif c'est pourqui monsieur c'est pour
toi chérie jean marc est belge et
cheveux comme j'ai pu inviter sa
maîtresse chez sa femme ça n'existe pas
wifredo depuis j'en sais plus et labiche
je fais ça chez toi en plus un mais
n'avait cédé pour qu'elle me rejoigne
non manon et dimanche 7 ça allait mal
ouais ça n'est pas très bien c'est vrai
ouais bah ça du tout après ça l'est plus
toi tu tournes et maîtresse à domicile
tant fait en même temps qu'est ce qui se
passe à la maîtresse à domicile ou de
votre humour n'ai pas pu rouvrir vous
allez fais des bandas à gilles verdez ah
oui si vous avez fait comme garde la
pluie ruisselle sur le bitume
y'a plus russell son avis elle sur le
bitume parisien
nous sommes en novembre 1997 je suis
parti acheter à manger et sur la route
du sandwich je trouve un couple réuni un
coût que j'adore un couple mythique
castaldi et flamands est là il reçoit un
sms
donc je vais les voir je me précipite
vers eux mais qu'est-ce que je suis
content de vous voir et tout ça vous
êtes le couple parfait quel est votre
secret pour durer
je vous admire depuis toujours vous êtes
les romantiques absolue et je vois qu'au
fil de mon enthousiasme
oui un malaise s'installe et donc et au
bout d'un moment la jeune femme est
simple et clair me dit gilles en fait
désolé on sort de chez le notaire on est
en train de divorcer
et là c'est la gaffe absolue ah ouais et
là vraiment elle m'a fait fermer ma
gueule tout de suite trouvé je suis
parti j'ai dit désolé devait s'y est pas
encore vous fermer
- les folles
je suis qu'aucun parce qu'elle est
encore rapport au sexe bas ont surtout
d'être qu'aucun bon d'ailleurs vous
étiez meilleurs qu'eux a en effet mais
quand même charger les mets en faut un
c'est vrai mais il s'est tout suis assez
incroyable d'excusés avec quelqu'un taux
courts lendemain battu l'appel pour
conclure me badat et je mets des
capteurs de votre slip mon portable
la juge a l'air cool bien parce que
l'histoire est vraie elle est vraiment
folle en plus aux coïncidences eu aucune
chance
un samedi soir je vais en boîte de nuit
y'avait pas d'expo jour là tous les
jambes obtenu givet hockey jarrier ou
non rémunérées et non rémunérées pas
j'arrive à l'aller les gens voient la
stèle d'une star arrivée bon retour
nanas à poil et vous c'était une soirée
thématique les toits ah oui tu es donc
j'ai un ballon à des des gens devaient
dire en quoi les roms billet paru il ya
pas beaucoup de filles ouf ouf pas non
une soirée gay
j'arrive et c'est vrai qu'il y avait le
choix est donc je décide de faire
plaisir à quelqu'un j'en choisis un très
beau je n'ai pas été très très beau et
jeune ramène à la maison et ça se passe
très bien
oui mais le terran très très beau et du
coup deux jours après je me retrouve à
un dîner chez des amis à paris et du
coup un peu fier de ma trouvaille je
monte mon téléphone et gym pour tous les
cas l'autre jour j'ai ken quelqu'un mais
un truc mes frères et moi c'était pas
plus urgent pour une photo oui bon il
mais pas pendant ces prêts à taux bas
quoi c'est pour la police après que
semaine et je montre à table la photo de
ma prise non merci sa table j'avais deux
ennemis des quatre hommes je connaissais
pas je te jure que cet or est vrai la
prob est impossible je le montre parmi
les quatre qui respectait son mec non
mais voilà on est tellement dans le rôle
qu'il a revécu l'histoire comme ses
copains et donc la maison s'est élevé
quoi il a quitté le dîner il est parti
non
oui mais qu'est ce qu'ils fassent les
syndicats c'est un gars était plus
costaud
j'adore ce serait du genre était plate
et ouais alors qu'à la leçon c'est quand
tu touches avec quelqu'un tu prends ta
photo du bec à tout le monde
non mais c'est ainsi que s'opère
désormais arriver tu couches avec une
bombe s'est contenté est quand même qui
sait quel show pessah
[Musique]